hello and welcome to another corrupted
game on VHS this is 15 plus 3 and I'm
playing n + VF yeah ok please rate the
2100 I'm currently I'm trying to get
better pollens higher rated opponents
but it is not not that easy to do in
fact I have tried to get yeah minimum
2200 but that was difficult so 2100 is
my minimum at the moment when I try
ok I'm playing an exchange variation of
the rule or path this is a very solid
line this line is 93 it's a special
weapon of yeah one of the one of the
coaches for my States Chess Federation
and he places frequently and has shown
some lines when we when we met a couple
of weeks ago for the German Youth
Championships they showed some lines to
students but I was present and I felt ok
why not give it a go yeah 93 is actually
a little bit different than castles
because after castles b5 is somewhat
hanging but there are some lines where
black can actually ignore the threat to
this because of the Queen d4 resource
now yeah now if 5 is paying for real and
this is one of those moves that covers
upon so here I have for some options d4
is the most straightforward one and I'm
going for it I wonder actually know
anything of it
it's my night correctly placed on c3
here
yeah Queen d4 f6
f 6 in those lines often right place 92
c4 in Castle castling but here I can't
castle long since this is really a bit
different okay I'm taking with this yeah
if six is more or less forced g7 is
hanging and there is no other way to
protect it
no there's no other move copy surprised
that it takes a while so um how would
you play here I think I should probably
go for long canceling
yeah so this should be three long and
maybe something that Queen d2 Bishop f4
trying to get rid of the bishop and the
Queen on D form is also sometimes able
to sidestep to c4 and prevent him from
canceling short okay probably just over
protecting five so I wanted to cancel
long anyway so might as well do it the
drawback of this is that the knight has
no clear development idea maybe Knight
h6 is the move but it's not something
you I happy with most of the time hmm
surprising
a little bit I'm sure what the ideas
does he really want to take in
you
Mehta would be strange your strange
decision what is this doing
okay I'm not question taking on c3 makes
no sense at all
maybe Bishop to b6 but I don't mind to
trade this absolutely not
hmm it's weird okay but what what am i
playing actually not that clear I like
this move somehow be sure before
something that might be honest agenda
and it prepares g4 also I'm really not
sure where to place my other pieces I
mean everything else is good the knight
cannot go to any of those squares
beehive or g5 and it could be improved
but I don't want to move it away maybe
he really wants to take and that would
be really nice I've called I just take
with the queen and sacrifice c4 pawn
lets not playable for black like takes
takes like takes takes Queen takes rook
e1 and I'm threatening Bishop c5 that's
that black can absolutely not claim now
I don't think so at least we know
development nothing no so what is he
doing just developing okay
yeah g4 certain idea gaining gaining
some space Knight to d4 is also
something that makes some sense yeah
maybe the kids gain this temple I mean
he wants to go to a5 it seems and that's
really not something that I mind very
much
you know what am i doing after it you
should be a 5
but entirely sure where I should put the
Queen I want to move the Queen and play
94 of it maybe just going to d3 like
Bishop a5 23 494 but that would step he
just goes back mysterious okay so
probably just centralized one idea is
that okay castle ignore would be very
funny hit Queen a7 and like here is in
terrible shape but even after rook da de
God creates heaven this is why I have
not yet moved to Queen and again
currently he has a problem with his
development the night I guess does not
want to go to age 6
now this allows Knight to d5 like it
seemed we should have form so good to
have and it prevents goodnight h6
completely yeah I guess you will
probably cancel long 95 is possible
now but it's not like non castled 95 you
can probably move the Queen to f7 maybe
I have a funny line a long castled 95
Queen f7 Bishop c5 Bishop c5 Knight b6
and I'm winning but it's not forced
after long castles 95 Queen f7 Bishop c5
this Bishop takes d5 and black yeah
we're a queen d5 no it doesn't work but
Bishop f4 is a simple move God going to
us and much time on that that's a good
move trailing off is Bishop a and the
structure remaining is pretty nice
expect him to take one f4 don't build
when you see a good move besides that
okay now Knight h6 is possible but he
has to reckon with Knight to d5
amongst others
and so it feels like quite comfortable
after the bishop has been taken off the
board so right here 986 if I call 95
Queen to f7 is there there is nothing
extremely promising I think I mean I can
just play technically I'll take
everything off and try to play an ending
maybe we should have false Alou the too
lame okay let's play let's play the
ending
now why does hoping for the king of porn
ending three three you know this stirred
good square yeah king upon ending would
be nice let us consider to be winning
even though you still have to be precise
something that I recently checked yeah
let's say it's a soul of given knowledge
that the King upon ending is winning for
white and exchanged way but it is
something that sin has to be done it's
not totally simply if you do it against
the computer you can easily fail I've
tried it it's not I didn't didn't do it
and 100% of the time okay so and for you
before you make fun of me tried out let
me go sale I've given this to a couple
of international masters and they also
did win every single one okay so we are
nearing or we have and we have gotten in
further simplifications this is
interesting because now he has to play
c4 c6 is a bit strange
isn't that funny that bishop has no
squares he has to go to the aid with the
night Prince really funny ok and then
just taking is probably good
I have 94 as well 94 I'm polish it has
to go back okay just retreats but yeah
King c3 should be pretty strong actually
a four a five also comes into
consideration but what is the strongest
team can I just win material here
you cannot move the b-pawn it drops a
six
I think it just loses a pawn c6 was a
very um very loose move in some way it
wasn't necessary awesome there was no
where I'm particularly need I believe to
play this yeah the exchange way is a
pretty good choice if you like a more
technical game it's less complicated to
play then the mainline we enter it so it
has some pilots and bite
I don't know what's best here to be
honest but good with the red of the best
defenses I looks pretty pretty bad
yeah I think the main problem was that
he played c6n that weakens enormous Lee
you usually want the b6 structure to
cover c5 I mean I think here black is
okay
also we play he tried b5 yeah sorry for
the drinking right it said it's a
terribly haughty and office
yeah the next step is night back to c5
and then I can try King before and then
f4 just move the majority forward the
other thing that is kind of promising is
support a knight on to c5 and where's it
going rather than steadfast anyway I
need to get it back Knight is really
nice 45 yeah so the alternative idea
then it's also quite good as a form
trying to get a passer with a 5 and yeah
I think that's a good choice if he takes
Knight takes and let b5 actually a
little bit annoying didn't happen ok so
now if I can get the get a passer
the next one I would do next is actually
really is before maybe play play to
cover this and if you take spawn takes
then before next that is pretty strong
to get it protected pong on 85 and then
push f4 and so on maybe I can also just
push at four immediately and 45 hardline
certainly to deal with the a and D pawn
and that b7 I'm happy to trade
no it's got nothing here you should
cannot move as also 96 don't see a good
way for him to to put out any resistance
this is not strictly necessary but I
think it's technically quite simple to
play like that
thank you a most likely capture Android
only to pre-movie I have got such a
comfortable time advantage ok so we are
talking before
yeah what is the next step to play here
probably I should try to improve the
knowledge m9 is not strong
maybe fh4 here is a move
you haven't many things will win I mean
f5 is likes idea it seems
can you play G form for one but now you
can do small improvement moves and then
see what happens this is useful anyway
f5 I have any five also yeah here Knight
f3 thought ring e5 and maybe with the
idea to play five myself
to be a bit cautious the Lego inside
this G form
one thing that he also has to keep in
mind is at a six always forcing them
they're forcing the King to be six or be
eight and then I have checked and Knight
f6 which actually picks up the the the
Bishop here for more or less nothing
oh no lost on time and gathering c6 was
the main the main thing that was the
prom so let's have a look at the
analysis board and have a look
interesting sometimes to follow the chat
yeah the exchange really is not a bad
opening for viruses from the black
players perspective I think it's not if
you play it with black and you know what
you're doing it's it's not super
threatening but it is something that is
a very low-risk thing that you can play
with white and you can you can win many
games and then use nothing if you play
it correctly I think okay so what 93
here f6 is by far the most popular move
after which it normally it goes like
goes like this this is how this normally
goes and then the bishop comes here
nitrate three and so on it's okay yeah
Bishop d6 so I play T form it takes yeah
he f6 is more or less for Scott Bishop
III looks completely normal
think and now Queen to e7 that was a bit
of a strange decision
I thought that e7 looks completely
normal then there should be six canceled
short this kind of thing yeah Queenie 7s
is difficult for him to develop yeah B
should be form I couldn't quite young
piece together what the idea was just
this looks normal I mean black is
slightly uncomfortable but erm
like a slightly uncomfortable it's
nothing special I mean probably do this
and a couple of use of all skin be one
Queen d2 Bush before these kind of
things we should be for botlane age
three
yeah the should [ __ ] it was a strange
bond where you should be find and going
back
so I centralized and no event c5 I am
the engine things Queen a4 is a lot
stronger BMP okay I was only thinking in
terms of Queen d2 Bishop f4 okay that
makes some sense M you should here in
Quincy fall and then you're ready for
this where that's true
yeah why does definitely better him
they're not better than my move I'm
keeping an advantage here but laughing
it's nothing fantastic of course not age
six and now I didn't really see anything
better than going into this is ending
well okay that's what you want is
opening then kill the engine thinks is
equal after which you won't know that
it's possible it's possible I really
went with this keep it simple method
just play simple moves the engine like
c5
yeah also it makes sense yeah I played
too superficially the engine gives like
0.1 you know I think it's just it just
equal distribution but it's still
something else you can definitely play I
mean it's not like an immediate draw
yeah c6 was a pretty bad mistake pretty
bad mistake you know kingda seven or
some some normal move here the relation
is like he has no good way now to play a
c4 is just strategically extremely
uncomfortable and otherwise the point is
lost
Oh fire is supposed to be better right
so I so take the pawn right now b6 is
given by the call okay because now I
cannot take a six but I can just take
this okay now about the computer already
wants to play b6 now but it also sucks
it's also winning ending yeah yeah you
don't really have much much choice here
like I expected him to take but the
position remains pretty terrible I think
like this and then like before king d4
and so on just no fun the a computer
keeps giving blacks like
some kind of mistake but it's lost our
way and there's really no way to put up
any resistance so I spoiled him a large
advantage by trading down to the ending
and the ending is equal but he has to
avoid c6 it was a really bad mistake
okay guys thanks for watching